hey everybody it's Jessie and today
we're going to keep working on this
section so I can get on the screen all
right so I figure we'll finish up this
section because we're almost there
so it's kind of didn't want to move on
to anything different and as you can see
I've got all the correct logos in here
now so I actually went back and looked
at my original code for this and luckily
when I first did this this is the format
that I put all the data for the logos in
I'm I'm not even really sure why I did
it like this because it was basically
like static a static page but I think I
was using handlebars for templating and
I just I did it like this obviously at
the time I didn't use Const because I
had no idea what that was whenever I did
this but and I you know I didn't do it
exactly like this but basically I had a
separate logos DOJ's file and it had
this data at the top and then passed it
into a handlebars template which is
awesome because I was really afraid I
was going to have to actually type out
this data
I had forgotten until about an hour ago
that I did it like this so I just copied
and pasted this over and in state I why
imported logos and instan state for data
and now it's logos so down here I'm
putting in I had that you know prefix
this with the actual paths and some
relative pass here and then I just add
the relative path on to the end and
everything's working so that was really
cool that was that was definitely a
time-saver so actually even for now I
don't have to do anything I can leave
these logos where they are I would
prefer to house them somewhere else just
so that I have better I guess control
over them because I can't directly the
directory that they're these are and now
that this is referencing I don't have
any access to that so what I had to do
initially was send all these files like
I literally had to email these files did
I email him it's possible that I was
given access to some sort of network
drive but in any case someone in the IT
department had to copy and paste
everything over because I wasn't allowed
to have access to it and I still don't
have access so I'd rather have have
these somewhere else so off the figure
out where the best place to house these
are and maybe you can let me know what
you think I'm not really I mean
obviously we're gonna have some sort of
server for this but all right I don't
know whose number that is sorry my
phone's ringing I don't know the number
so I'm not gonna answer usually if I
don't know the number there's somebody
trying to sell me something where was I
unless my train of thought oh okay so
obviously we're gonna have some sort of
node server to run this but I don't
really know should i house the files on
that same server or is there a better
place that I could house the files I'm
thinking like maybe there's some sort of
out-of-the-box thing that I haven't done
before that might be cool to try so let
me know if you know of anything like
that and and then we'll see what like I
said we don't have to figure that out
really at all for a while I think I am
just a little bit nervous since I don't
have access to that folder I can't if
something were to happen
I'd rather get the files out of there
and at least backed up somewhere else if
something were to happen I'm pretty sure
I have all these backed up at the very
least on on my computer possibly in a
cloud drive somewhere but I would still
feel better if it's in a different spot
so that's pretty much all I've done I
had a few pull requests I think they're
all pretty minor I had some from Kevin
one from Sebastian kind of editing some
environment variables so that we don't
when you're testing it doesn't send a
lot of projects to rike when when
testing the service request form and yes
you can check out I think it was like 37
38 and 39 with the pool request numbers
if you want to check those out and I
think that's all it's Oh big change
I forgot that I changed this so I
changed the layout a bit in terms of how
the logos are displayed so yesterday we
just had the logos and not in cards I
wanted to see what it would look like if
I put them in cards obviously I would
want to space this out a bit I mean it
there needs to be
some space between these but other than
that my reasoning for wanting to put
them in cards were that currently these
all have white backgrounds possibly some
have transparent backgrounds but some of
them definitely have white backgrounds I
don't think all of them might I could do
transparent and our background here is
that kind of grey color but in the live
site is white so it works that it looks
like all the logos are just the logos
but when the logos are up against the
gray you can see the white outline which
I didn't think looked very good so I
thought okay well if they're gonna look
like there's a square of white around
them anyway or a rectangle why not make
it a card the other thing that I needed
was I needed a way to be able to click
either you know JPEG or PSD so I'll show
you what it looks like right now so
here's the effect that I have right now
when you hover these two little kind of
buttons come up one says web one says
print we went back and forth initially
as to what we should call this like
would people understand what a JPEG is
what a PSD is and what they should use
them for so we ended up going with web
and print because generally that's what
people would end up using them for I
think I've clicked tracking on all these
so I may be able to find out are people
actually clicking these and which one
they're they're really clicking more do
we really need both but for now I I kind
of I didn't really want to do the same
effect and you all can let me know how
you think this looks I'm just not I'm
not sure I'm not sure that I like it
just seems it seems like there's a lot
going on I think maybe I've gotten to
like
more simplistic design since I've done
this kind of less motion so I'm not
really I don't really like that when you
hover the not only does the logo appear
you know to grow but then you also have
these and then there's even a hover
effect on these so I just I'm not really
sure what I want to do with it right now
I've just been kind of looking at it a
lot and trying to visualize what it
could be so I don't want to change it
dramatically because I want users to
still be familiar with what they're used
to so we need do something with that we
also need to do something with with
these here not really sure that how they
currently are I don't really know that I
like that but I'm I'm not exactly sure
what I want to do with that either
so I'm open to your ideas
sometimes when I get to this point and I
want to make a change but I'm not sure I
like design inspiration elsewhere so
I'll go through usually like other sites
that use material design and see how
they've handled similar use cases and
usually I can get some inspiration I I
really don't like to let's say copy
anybody's design exactly because I don't
know there's just something in me that
wants to do it once that my own kind of
spin on it but I do like to see how it's
how it's handled so maybe I'll do some
of that we'll see but there are a few
things that definitely need need worked
on now so we need to connect the data to
these buttons for the links to be able
to work I'd like to be able to add the
correct alt text titles to these images
definitely add some space between these
cars still not sure if we'll keep the
cards on or not and possibly even some
padding but I don't like how that is
touching the sides there most of the
other logos are okay but some of them
some of them still touch all right so
that's that's basically an overview of
the the problems that we're gonna try to
to solve today and we'll see how far we
get and and what we come up with I just
pushed to the github repo and let me
check this time because yesterday I
thought I pushed and then I had some
errors and so I went like for an hour
without realizing that the code wasn't
updated but in fact it was updated and
it didn't work so the latest version of
the code is in the master branch in the
git repo for this project the links in
the description so you all can check
that out I'm gonna check the live chat
before I start the Pomodoro timer just
to see what y'all think I know I asked
several questions at the beginning so
and I haven't checked or any answers yet
so we're gonna do that also I guess a
for anybody's no I I haven't done like
the the normal what's this show about I
think for a while so for anybody who's
new that's watching I'm a front-end
developer and this is me doing my
everyday work so it's not rehearsed I'm
gonna make mistakes we're gonna try to
work through them it's not exactly a
tutorial although I try my best to
explain what I'm doing and at various
levels even even some basic things
because we have people of all skill
levels in here feel free to ask any
questions
I'll take breaks periodically to answer
questions and then at the end I'll try
to answer every question that I had
missed throughout the show let's see
there's a second stream on Instagram
that's a view of me as I'm coding and my
office so you can check
if you want to it's kind of just more
like a novelty thing because obviously
the main thing is the code and not not
really my face but occasionally people
check in and I guess maybe they're
curious to see what would I look like
what my office looks like and if you
happen to be watching this on Instagram
of the recording check out the free code
camp YouTube channel and you get a
better idea of what I'm doing because
you'll be able to see the code in my
screen okay so enough enough
introduction let's check out would you
all have to say about this project and
some of the problems that I want to say
problems so some some of the use cases
and issues we're gonna we're going to
deal with so okay so I did I had a
comment a while before the stream
started so I'm not even sure if so this
is from mine blocks coder not sure if
you're still watching but mine blocks
coder said maybe you should try doing
streams earlier I've thought about doing
different times occasionally I do
streams at different times in fact this
week I've done I varied the times I
think last week I did an early stream
which it would have been in the morning
for my time zone but I'm certainly open
to changing the time that I do these
this time in the afternoon seems to be a
good time to where I can be most
consistent I do have some meetings that
I always have let's say like in the
morning so if I were to change it to a
different time earlier I probably
couldn't be consistent every day with
that time but I'm open to it
just let me know let me know what you
think let me know in the live chat but
it might actually be more helpful to put
a comment to this video and then that
way I'll be able to see it you later on
so especially for the people who are
gonna watch the recording obviously the
live stream is not a good time for you
so let me know when a good time would be
preferably if you could figure out when
that time would be in Eastern time that
would be great but otherwise if you
don't want to do
that just let me know what timezone
urine as well so I could figure out what
time that would be for me and I'm
definitely open to trying that I think
it would be cool to let other people be
able to participate in the live stream
but otherwise I'm gonna try to stick
with this time unless unless I I find
out that there's a significant number of
people who would rather have it at a
different time
cool Mayank says great work dude thank
you thank you I appreciate that thanks
for watching Abhishek's is nicely done
thanks to you thanks you all are very
very kind today to start out with so hey
everyone a few people were saying hi
okay so I did ask a question about where
to store these images Patrick says maybe
AWS s3 Rohan says let's not go for the
nucular off so maybe that would be
overkill for what we need but actually I
do these small projects and sometimes I
do think that the way I do some of them
might be overkill for that particular
project but but keep in mind what I'm
trying to do with these small projects
is not only fulfill all of the
requirements for that particular project
but prepare for larger projects so the
main website for my university with the
Franciscan ddu knees redone I think it's
badly in need of being redone because
the site is very very slow and that not
to mention design outdated you know
there's there's a lot of things that
need updated but the number one thing
for me is nobody's going to stick around
even see what it looks like because the
load times are insane and I've gotten
the load times down about as far as I
think I can given the current system so
all of these small projects I want to
test out something that I know I'll
probably need with a larger project so
while it might not be necessary for a
smaller project in in the bigger picture
of what I'm trying to do as a
whole I need that test I need to be able
to prove it I'd like to be able to say
to my boss and the people higher up who
are gonna have to approve things all the
I'd like to be able to either they have
my plan to say hey all these things that
I'm saying that I can do I've done them
here with this site that site that site
so they can actually go and see it and
see that it works and that I've tested
it because it is gonna sound a bit crazy
when I propose all this it's going to be
much different than their current set up
which you know the set up is just a
traditional dotnet based content
management system hosted on Windows
servers here on campus in our IT
department a very old-school set up so
what I'm proposing just you know briefly
is a react site pulling data from
content management system
maybe WordPress but then having just
heavy caching to handle the load and
load balance across I don't know maybe
like half a dozen digital ocean droplets
to handle to where like copies of all
the react apps will be potentially
drawing data from multiple WordPress
installs from different sites so that
concept is really foreign I think to to
a lot of people so it would be great to
be able to say like hey we've done it so
if you notice in the last project we did
the load balancing right we pulled in
data from WordPress so anyway hopefully
you understand what I'm saying because I
have had people ask definitely more than
once like why are you doing it like this
do you really need to do that and that's
really why I mean I do want to make
really good sites so it's cool to try to
use the latest thing even if I you know
don't have to but I'm trying to prove by
actually doing these things that my plan
will work for the main site so anyway
sorry that was a long time spent
on what wasn't even really a question
from you just they it just popped into
my head but it does it it is an answer
to questions I've received previously
about the same topic okay david says
what about storing them in manga or
something yeah I'm thinking about that
I'm I'm actually considering some sort
of database they said don't really know
if it's necessary but once again like
it's not it's not just about what's
necessary for the project it's about
what what should I be testing and
learning to prepare for other projects
that I know I'll need to do Sebastian
said card style looks good
the hovering button kind of overkill
yeah okay Sebastian says the card style
so I'd asked what you all think about
this so he said sir card style goes
straight to the point you see the image
choose the format really simple okay
yeah that's kind of what I thought you
you know the hover you have to actually
hover over the image see it's not even
apparent what you're supposed to do with
these images you would think somebody
would try to click but I've I've noticed
that people who aren't really that
familiar with technology they don't use
it a lot they're not really inclined to
move around and click there their
mindset is well like if I don't move or
click anything I won't mess it up
which is kind of weird because obviously
I'm sure all of us
when we go into a website we're like I'm
clicking and hovering everything like I
want to see how this thing works that's
because that's what we do you know but I
can't rely on that you know other people
don't always work like that so I agree
Sebastian I think it would be better to
have it more straightforward like this
but still open I still don't I just
don't love how this looks so I'm trying
to think of a way to make it look a bit
better I mean maybe it'll look better
when I put in the proper
you know spacing here we'll see well
we'll mess around with it today and see
what it looks like
Rohan said watching the Instagram stream
where is the mic you mean like like
we're actually like you can't see the
mic in the image or is the mic messed up
on the Instagram stream so you can't
hear my voice so while I'm waiting for
the delay and the answer to that
I'll get do another take another
question so code BCC says what's a good
resource to learn front-end development
I'm experienced on the backend wanting
to get into front-end and Sebastian says
for basics check free code camp and then
Udacity and learn code Academy yeah I
definitely agree those are great
resources that'll that'll get you on the
right path for sure alright David said
watching from Ireland so don't make it
too early yeah that's the thing if I
change the time it'll work better for
some people but worse for others there's
not really any way around it you know we
have people from from all over the world
so I you know I don't know maybe maybe I
can try to vary so that I don't I don't
know some days a week I'll do it in the
afternoon some days in the morning and
then I don't know I'll think about it
okay Patrick must have visited the main
site franciscans edu and he says it's
brutally slow yes yes it is Rohan says I
would suggest a common static content
CDN or just a different droplet for all
sites going forward I like that idea I
like that we had thought about that
before for different projects and yeah
that would
really useful rowan says clicking and
hovering I have dev tools open all the
time I didn't want to I didn't want to
go that far with it but I'm the same way
you know I have my my browser extension
here right so it tells me what
everything's built from all the time so
I'm always looking at this and then also
going to dev tools if I see something
odd like you know or just I just want to
know how did they do that
so yeah I'm right with you there oh okay
so we're gonna ask the mic for YouTube
recording it's in there actually yeah
it's hard to get the mic and me in the
recording at the same time so yeah I
just tried it I'm kind of like my face
is way off to the side and you can't
really see all of it so anyway it's a
nod I have to have it at a far enough
away from the mic so that it doesn't
cause interference but then it also
makes it so that basically the angle of
it is coming like from where I have the
live chat the screen that I have the
live chat on so when I'm looking at the
live chat it's a decent angle because
I'm looking pretty much right at the the
camera for on my phone but when I look
at the code I'm I'm turned completely
you know kind of sideways you get a side
profile of me but not really anything I
can do about it I'd rather have the mic
be in the central location so everyone
can hear because as I said I mean I
consider the the Instagram just kind of
a secondary novelty thing oh cool Rowan
says the audio on YouTube is very
consistent even though you move a lot
awesome
yeah the mic is basically like as in the
middle as I can get it without blocking
a screen so
so far it's been working out well
actually it was a really cheap mic I got
it like on Amazon for it was a good deal
I want to say it was like less than $15
or something but it got good reviews so
I thought it was worth a shot
okay let's get to some code so Gavin did
ask did he complete the logo screen and
the last live think so I didn't exactly
complete it I we got we got to the point
where we had some of this up here but we
just had some like test testing so it
wasn't these this content of these names
and we had some like just one image in
here to test but it actually wasn't even
loading so we added a little broken
image icon but it was enough to test
that they were getting on the page and
then when we clicked these up here it
did it changed since then I put I pulled
in data for all the images so that we
could get all the the actual images that
are gonna be on this once it's live and
I put it in some cards and then I also
put in the proper name so in terms of
code you can see I just put these in up
here it's not really a super long list
so I'm kind of okay with it being here
but I could see like it might make sense
to move this somewhere else as well I
could I could move it over here to this
file and export that as well
so we'll see I will if this starts to
get long right now it's so short it just
doesn't bother me if it starts to get
longer maybe we'll move it maybe you
know just to keep things clean but for
now this is here and then all the data
is over here in this logo data j/s and I
have a new directory called data and
that's where that's in so
haven't haven't really done a lot it
looks on the screen like it's a pretty
big change but you know in terms of the
code it's it's not really a lot so let's
set the Pomodoro timer and start doing
something
so if you if you're not familiar with
what we're doing here I set the timer I
code for 25 minutes and then I take five
minutes and I check in with the live
chat if I need to check in with a live
chat like I'm stuck if I have a question
or something I will check in
occasionally even during that 25 minutes
but this just kind of keeps a nice pace
so that I don't spend too much time on
one or the other all right so first
things first I absolutely know that I
want to add some spacing in here so
let's work on that first and then
that'll give my brain like a little bit
of time to think about what I want to
try to clean this up so we need spacing
here and then we need to add some
padding to these cards yeah so that's
yeah that's definitely I definitely want
to do that
okay so right now I probably can just
add a bottom see so we have our sass
file for logos so I'm gonna try to do as
much as I can in the sass file otherwise
something like this I would probably
make an inline style but since we have a
sass file let's try to keep this as
clean as we can so at times we don't
want tabs we want
I'm trying I guess where I think the
only cards will actually have will be
logos I'm interested to see what this
comes out as
so it looks like alright we don't really
have by default there's not really a
class for those cards that we can use so
I'm gonna have to add a class which is
not a big deal I figured out out of
class anyway so class and we're gonna do
class name because in react you can't
use just class okay obviously react is
like you know using javascript in here
and class is used you know for other
things in javascript so we have to do
class name camel case then we can add
our class names just as we normally do
so I think logo card is the decent name
for this and so now we can go logo card
and let me think
twenty four pixels let's try 24 pixels
anything
oh you know what
it looks like the class didn't
it looks like the class wasn't applied
so let's let's do this let's just take
this up we don't really need that I'm
sure there's a way to add a class on
here I don't know maybe I did it wrong
but this will work too oops
actually what am I doing with these
camelcase look
it's the only thing I've noticed that
messes me up and only sometimes when I'm
doing you know react
so with this JSX you switch back and
forth between camelcase
and then when you're using the CSS not
in line you normally use hyphens so
occasionally
I'll use them in the wrong place let me
make this bigger I'm sorry I forget I
made this smaller earlier so that I
could see more of the code and I didn't
make it bigger littler container and
then we're gonna say yeah actually let's
see if it'll work just on the container
I wanted to put it on the card but I
don't think it'll really matter and I
guess it will now let's see did this
okay so the class did get applied
[Music]
it actually didn't apply our margin
hmm
alright I'm gonna check the chat really
quick because this seems like one of the
times where I made a silly mistake and
you all would probably catch it it's
misspelled okay awesome thank you
cont a thank you I'm glad I remembered
to check the live chat if you haven't
watched before then you probably don't
know what I was talking about but often
it happens that when I have an issue
I'll try for you know 5-10 minutes to
figure it out on my own and then I'll
look at the live chat and realize that
right away somebody usually more than
one person has caught my mistake and
told me about it and I just didn't think
to look over so thank you for that let's
see I don't know
there we go
all right so we are getting that margin
on the bottom
I'm not sure where that's our
margin-bottom is not even showing up
though in dev tools which is weird
I have dev tools open on my other screen
oh okay I see it it's just really far
down down the list okay so that took
longer than expected due to mainly just
the type of yeah I like that I may put a
media query in there and make it smaller
on on mobile I know on mobile I might
actually we'll see how it looks and how
much time I want to put into this but I
kind of like the idea of not having the
cards or basically having the cards take
up the entire width and then just having
a line dividing them so it almost really
wouldn't be a card anymore so you can
see in the material design spec they
there are examples of that I mean
there's also examples of material design
apps that will use cards in a row like
this as well so I've seen it both ways
we'll just I'll see I'll get out my
phone and test on there and see what
it's like okay
now let's add our padding actually
around our cards and
maybe now that I think about it it would
be useful to have a class on here
where's our component
okay
what do you think do I need to pass this
down as a prop and then put it on here
because I'm I'm almost positive that
this has worked before to just add the
class name directly on to a component
and it it works it comes out in the
final markup I mean maybe it's just the
way the components are set up
okay
classes
whose
there we go
that's why syntax highlighting is really
nice and that you get used to how things
are the color it's supposed to be so you
immediately know when you mess something
up because it doesn't change to the
color that you know it should be so in
that case I knew I was doing something
wrong here I didn't actually catch what
it was immediately I ended up trying to
adding this into here thinking it had
something to do with with this in
reality it was because I was I put this
in quotation marks instead of in curly
brackets but it's better in the end
anyway but now it's more consistent so
let's see if this works now so what I'm
trying to do here then is just pass
whatever classes that I want this to
have down to this component to see if
then it will actually work as a class
name since it wasn't before
yep and now it does work so now we do
these do have the class name of logo
card so now we can use that in our in
our sass file the card if you're not
familiar with sass you can nest CSS
rules like that and basically that would
be the same as if I did you know logo
card container and then logo card and in
regular CSS so it basically gets turned
into that as soon as I save it and it
gets saved in a the logos dot CSS file
just a lot less to type out especially
when your nesting things not really a
great idea to nest things too deep it
gets kind of messy but you know 3d I'm
okay with three deep start getting like
four more than probably
not really necessary alright so on the
logo card we want padding so let's give
it some padding
I don't want top or bottom padding right
now let's see I should probably check to
see now actually I do want there it
looks like there's no top padding
currently that makes sense see now that
I think about it we don't really need
padding on the whole thing
we just need padding around this section
around the image section so that
currently the div that holds the image
does not have a class let's see if we
can find it and if that would be easy
okay card media overlay I'm not the
overlay we want the the image
hmm
if we're gonna put a clasp anywhere
it'll probably be here so let's do it
mr. container all right hopefully okay
well that's not too bad it got actually
on the outer div so that's I don't know
why there it's nested two divs actually
one two yeah there's two days probably
because one of them ends up being the
overlay and the other one is the
container but for now since we're not
having an overlay on these I'm okay with
that
and we can just select that image
container
and I'll spell container right this time
and then now we can do let's give it a
pixel all the way around I'm not exactly
sure why I'm sure there's a good reason
for it but for some reason and material
design it seems like things go in 8th so
you know you have 8 pixels 16 pixels and
like normally that normally you see
mostly just 8 and 16 a lot in the
documentation so that's what I normally
start with and that usually seems to
work pretty well and it looks right with
the rest of what's going on in material
design all right not bad although now
that I look at it it probably is a good
idea to not include the padding at the
bottom because we have quite a bit of
white space here so I think that's
that's just not necessary so let's take
this and we'll go eight eight zero and
then eight alright so if if you're not
familiar with this way of writing this
in CSS when you do all four it goes top
right bottom left if you were just going
to do two it's the first one is top and
bottom and then the second one is right
and left
and it looks like did I mess it up
I must have messed something up because
it does not look what did I did
what did I do wrong
you still have our image container Oh
silly mistake
no and no commas there we go nope so I'm
just gonna leave that up there for
another second so do not put commas in
between these I don't know why I did
that okay I like that better it's not a
huge difference I mean I can see cuz I
was really looking for it not it's not
something that would jump out at you as
a change but I think overall if you're
talking about all these cards it's a
significant decrease in the overall
amount of scrolling that you have to do
to get around you know if you add up all
those eight pixels then down the line
okay that looks better we have some
padding it could probably do with a
little bit more padding but I'm okay
with that I don't want these images to
be too small in comparison to the cards
because you know the logo images are the
the whole point of the page it's the the
focus all right so I'm gonna go ahead
and commit this because you know
basically this is just margin and
padding stuff it goes together before we
move on to anything else be good time to
commit this will also be a good kind of
example of how to commit I know I give I
go through this example frequently but I
figure I'm sure there's there's always
you know somebody possibly new who
hasn't seen it who's just starting out
maybe hasn't even used yet before so in
the terminal we we already have have
gone through some installation and setup
to have get running so this definitely
there takes something to get to this
point but once you have get running if
you want to commit which is like
basically a snapshot of your project at
that point in time then here's how you
do it first thing I always do is
get status and that might be a little
bigger
I'd sight get status this look this lets
me know what files have changed this is
really good you may have accidentally
changed the file will not realize that
and then this will remind you
but maybe you changed something that you
didn't you shouldn't have and this is a
way to catch it otherwise this at least
will verify that hey the stuff that I
wanted to change is in fact change and
these are the things that we've changed
so now I'm gonna do a git commit and
this is kind of a shorthand we're gonna
put a flag here we're gonna put the a
flag which means add so we're gonna
combine two steps normally you would get
add and then you would get commit but
we're combining them so we're gonna get
commit and then with a and we're gonna
put em em means we get to put a message
right in line and with with this commit
if we didn't put the M when we hit enter
it would bring up whatever our default
editor was and we have to type the
message in there but for now I'll just
say add padding to those margin two cars
yeah
and in terms of the commit message there
are different ways that people like to
do that and there are some standard ways
so I'd say maybe just check out the way
that is recommended by some of how other
companies do it and things and you know
figure out what way works for you if
it's a small project is just you working
on it
not a huge deal but if you're working
with a lot of other people you
definitely want to have some sort of
standard way to do commit messages all
right so the commit has gone through
normally you won't see all of this stuff
this is unique to our project that we
have all these tests running and some
auto formatting but you will see this
part here at the bottom if it's worked
so three files change and it lets us
know 14 insertions four deletions great
now we want to make sure this gets
synced up to a repo on github so we type
git push that's gonna push the code up
to github origin/master
so we're pushing the master branch there
we go great everything works now if we
were not gonna go there but if we were
to go to the git repo the code would be
exactly the same as it is on our local
machine great and that was perfect
timing so now we can take five minutes
go over to the live chat get answer some
questions and then we'll come back to
the code
all right so I'm gonna swell there's a
actually a lot in the live chat so you
all have been busy that's awesome I like
when the live chat is Lively all right
so I'm gonna have a lot to catch up on I
don't think I'll get through everything
in this five minutes I'll have to have
to catch up at the end
okay I see you I've given me a lot of
different suggestions for four databases
for storing the images so I'm seeing all
that I'll save all those so I can refer
to them and then see about maybe check
them out and see which one we should use
okay Brian I just saw your comments
there about the border on the links so
is saying it's just it says not clear
he's saying it's not clear UI without
some sort of distinction between the
buttons and the background so there
should be some type of border
distinction
okay and just to clarify let me know if
are you referring to these or these or
both I mean obviously this does have a
hover effect but I could see your
comment could definitely apply to both
so let me know what you were thinking
specifically if you're still if you're
still watching if you're still here
please let me know
tech neck technique Renault says
Pomodoro bruh yes Pomodoro he says I
can't even do more than 5 minutes of
coding before I visit reddit /youtube
you got it it's easier to focus if you
do the Pomodoro because you know it's
like all right 25 minutes I'm gonna
ignore everything except the code I'm
not saying I always do that but when I'm
in the zone I definitely do like I do my
25 minutes I ignore everything and then
I do my best during the 5 to just not
think about the code and then just go
right back to it
so that's best case scenario that's how
it works sometimes you get interrupted
and you can't ignore it it's important
but otherwise the Pomodoro is nice
because you it it helps if you know you
only have to focus for a certain amount
of time and it's a relatively short
period of time and then you can relax
for a little bit if you're just saying
like man I got hours and hours of work
let's just get to it that's pretty tough
right like if you're running a marathon
like you don't just sprint the whole way
right you're never gonna gonna make it
but like if you if you would knew you
could take breaks along the way then you
might sprint and then rest and sprint
and then rest and that would be
legitimate and doable would be like
interval training but this is the same
thing with your brain right it's I don't
know hopefully that made sense hopefully
you all know what I'm talking about
at least it works for me i but I've I
think at least some somewhat that's the
idea behind it técnicos says I'm 37 and
my attention span is as long as my baby
daughter
Joshua says I did over 1 hour and 30
minutes of coding and I'm 10 Wow so
Joshua 10 years old and doing coding
that's awesome thanks for watching
hopefully you're getting something
useful out of this that's that's really
cool my my oldest is 8 years old and
really interested in getting him more
and you know excited about coding
getting kind of into it so you'll have
to let me know let me know what what you
really like about coding as a young
person maybe that'll that'll help me out
with with my kids
let's see Blake asks what local web
server is he using I was in nginx ok
Patrick says it's a hot module reloading
with webpack it said Joshua says
question in my website when I put done
the code for buttons the buttons only
affect the first questions help me
please
ok cool it looks like so it looks like
some of you in the live chat are helping
out Joshua with with this code question
so Joshua let let me know if you need
extra help you know let me know I don't
know if you're on Twitter or anything
that usually if people need extra help
they message me on Twitter but you can
you can put it in the comments on
YouTube or however whatever is best for
you if you want to email it that's cool
too
okay my five minutes is up so I'm going
to stop going through the live chat and
I'll come back to it after our next
session is over
let's see I do want to see Blake's
Blake's answer
okay or I'm sorry not Blake Brian's
answer about the buttons so Brian says
the hover effect is good once you're
hovering over it but a border would make
it very clear for the user without
having to navigate and guess okay
okay cool let's check that out actually
so I think we have more options than
this built in to material UI at least
there was for materialized I'm assuming
we have it materialized so let's just
check out what they have and see if
it'll fit what we're trying to do so
should be under
it looks like they don't let me check
out materialized I I really thought
there was another another style but I
remember seeing
maybe not maybe where did I see that I
guess I didn't so I the only the
difference in materializes they do have
this border here I kind of like that I
may add this in I do like that
distinction now they've gone with a
slightly different so they the same
color that's used throughout for links
is used for the button so that would be
a visual cue so I like that
let's go to material design guidelines
just to double-check and see what
they're doing
okay so similar so their basic example
actually does look well it's so much the
combination so it does not have the the
line there the the border but it does
have the accent color let's see what
kind of options
okay so adhere this this is actually the
style that it's your UI is using okay
okay here we do have the border so it
looks like all of these options within
material design are valid they're used
but yeah so I'm not seeing
not seeing a border
so we're not really gonna get any ideas
I think from material design spec
because it looks like they're not using
that but I'm almost positive that I've
done it before so let me just check out
a few of the sites that I've done I'm
gonna bring up on my other screen and
I'll pull them over if I find it I use
cars that I know
all right let's check this out
hmm
Wow I must be losing my mind even so
I've been consistent throughout all my
sites and that basically I have used the
card actions without border but I have
always done
I've capitalized it and I've used the
link color which is usually you know
your accent color so a lot of times I do
this sometimes I do a blue depends on
the color scheme for the site I think
I've even done I did read for the last
project and I think I've gone with a
slightly darker or a slightly heavier
font weight so let's just see how it
looks with that I kind of want to add I
want to see what it looks like with that
line I think it'll probably look a
little bit better so I'm gonna add in
the line I'm gonna change this to a
color that is the same link color that
we're using on the rest of the site and
we'll see how that looks
I don't think I use this hover effect in
any of my other sites I'm not opposed to
using it now okay
color
I should probably let me grab this color
first and see how it looks I'm still I'm
not really sure that I want to keep this
color yet but at least it'll just give
us something something to look at
all right so if we go in here image
continue should be able to do
what I should do is put make all these
colors variables and then have like
maybe like a color CSS file and then
import it which maybe we'll do that at
some point but for right now I think
this will be okay
area
okay so we have that let's see
so dude there we go so we want
here's a border let me bring this over
because I'm I keep referring to this
might be a good idea if I show it so
basically I've just done on this div
which contains our action items I've
just done a border obviously I don't
want to keep it that gray color let's go
with maybe 54 see how that looks and
that's still too dark
there we go that looks better if I
decide to keep it I'll look up what it
actually is and materialize but
actually I have a thought
[Music]
what we really want people to do when
they go to the logos is download a logo
but we're not actually saying anywhere
downloaded the logo and we may be doing
that here at the top so that I'd like to
check out what language we we have there
already okay so we are saying please
select a logo to download so we're
giving some direction so maybe we ought
to have say download maybe we should say
download here and then give them these
options and then that would make it it
would make it clear the action that
should be taken
okay yeah what do you think
let's let me grab this and we don't have
a class for that yet so let me just put
it over here for now we'll see about
adding a class but I think I need you I
need a title
let's go so you could see here so here's
a generic card here we go card title
yeah
how do we do that I'm gonna have to look
back at how we originally imported all
the all the different options so I can't
remember how we did it for that generic
card component I thought I had it up
available on a screen beforehand I guess
not
so let's go back we're gonna find
so in actually in our logos view we had
an example
oops yeah this is it
so we had an example of the cards there
we go
that's what we want to see
so we can go back so this is one of the
great things about get also in github
that we can go back to all these
previous versions and see so even though
this hasn't been in that file for a
little while we've we've had many save
since then we can still check it out so
what I'm interested in is card title
there we go that's what I think we'll
probably want and then we'll also
no that's not what I wanted sorry about
that
what I wanted was this one okay so yeah
here we go
so card title and port that and then
let's see yeah we did okay so we just
put a string in and that's what title
okay
that's pretty straightforward but
nothing wrong with double-checking I
guess so I'm gonna put it here just
because this is how it appears you know
on the page so it makes sense to me to
be right there
let's see how that looks not not really
sure
mm yeah okay I don't like that it's way
too much space wait he was
well Lisa gives us something to look at
yeah this part is hard I guess it's hard
to share what I'm seeing in my head
with all of you unless I actually put it
on here so so be some trial and error
this part if I get rid of this part
maybe he would look better
okay
actually I don't dislike this as much
I'm still not sure I don't like that
it's very repetitive saying download
every time but I'm not sure all right
I'm gonna go to the live chat cuz I've
I've tried a few things here and I want
to see what would you all think alright
looks like somebody had a good idea
except I'm seeing people saying like
like this idea so let me scroll up and
try to find the beginning of this idea
okay John Hanson said asked with this
material you I have a download icon that
is a great idea
so let's check it out
sweet so download icon that could work
now this material UI it has their own
icons correct let's see okay you can't
do it
so I if you remember from the last
project I prefer to use SVG icons
instead of font icons for several
reasons one if you use an SVG icon I
usually now in this case it's I'm not
sure how they're bringing in the SVG
icons but when I do it on my own I only
bring in just the one that I need and I
put the the actual SVG you know code
right there in line so nothing has to
load there's no network requests with
font icons I mean you have it at least
one Network request to get the font and
you're getting extra icons that you
probably never use I mean really you
only use I mean maybe I never use more
than a dozen font icons on any site and
probably usually no more than a half a
dozen and a fawn icon set could come
with a lot more than that you could do a
custom font icon set which I've done
before as well to try to keep it small
but the other thing I don't like about
font icons are I've had issues with
different browsers not displaying them
properly and it was it's been hard to
troubleshoot because I can't always
replicate the issue I've gotten
screenshots from users so I know it's it
is happening but then it's difficult to
to kind of really see what's going on so
I've never had that problem with SVG
icons so that's why I prefer SVG's
so let's check out how they do it
okay so it looks like they already have
some they already do have some
components
well let's see do they have a list of
these somewhere so if they have a
download icon which seems like a pretty
common icon already we may be able to
just use that like they're doing here
actually I'm just gonna guess because if
I added a file download icon and I was
naming it like this then I'm gonna guess
unless one of you already let's see I'm
not sure you see or don't I come on it
looks like brown already found it I it
took a little bit of the fun out of it
but it'll probably be faster this way I
was just going to try to guess based on
what they were naming I mess it up
let's see
my eye just saw as I was looking over
the live chat Curtis asked can I use
this project on my portfolio yeah I
guess so I mean are you saying you want
to help work on this project and put it
in your portfolio then yeah I mean yeah
that's fine because whatever commits you
have are certainly yours or you wanted
to use the project as the basis to build
your portfolio on I'm fine with that as
well so either way a hum is fine with me
okay so since that link didn't work
let's try this
all right so what I've done here is I've
just guessed
really what the name should be and this
is really I could have looked it up but
I just thought it would be fun to guess
so I'll try it if it doesn't work then
I'll I'll look it up I went to that oh
it's here
icon style is just not define define
like 50 all right so say it's not gonna
work
950 oh let's get rid of that did you see
okay so it didn't find the module all
right we'll look it up
there we go
ICG icons
actually did I add this I don't remember
if I added this that might be why we
can't get it let's check it out
I don't I don't have it to you I I cough
so let me I've obviously have some icons
right because we like we have an icon
let me get rid of this so how am I using
icons
so see like obviously we have an icon so
all right so what do you think real
quick I only want to take maybe like two
minutes on this is it worth it to pull
in the entire material you I I con do
you think we'll use that many icons that
it's worth it or should I just grab the
SVG really quick and and put it in there
from material icons
which one when I just download that now
just in case we end up using it
okay importing named exports in this way
yeah
okay this might not even work because I
might not be using that all right cool
everybody thinks we should just do the
SVG really quick and that is fine with
me because that's what I am used to
doing anyway so see look at that that's
so it's so simple like this tiny amount
of code like you just copy and paste it
really simple there okay so let's do
this let me see if I can let's see if I
can pass it in here if it'll work
yeah it works okay awesome so we have it
downloaded not not ideal right now yeah
I might just get rid of this effect
and then we need to put in some text I'm
not sure let's see if it'll let me do
this
where's the shot yeah they're not
working so let's
no that works well at least we get what
we wanted on the screen I don't know why
I could thought I thought that I could
do the first thing now that I think
about it it was really obvious that that
would not work all right so I need to
change obviously need to make this line
up a little bit better but what do you
think I mean it's for the hotel maybe I
should line it up better because it
looks really weird right now
let's see what's going on here
I could probably just make this bigger
and then it might work sort of height
with
let's just double it see what that does
well way too big
yes you small for sure okay we need to
make this bigger
I just took a display flex-a-lite I'm
sorry
all right cool thank you John Hansen I
just saw your ear advice
let me gonna get rid of that
mmm nope see that on the wrong element
I don't know
okay okay try a line items
maybe I should put this text in its own
span and then I could move it
independently that way like potentially
maybe I could give it a little bit of
padding and just bump it up that might
not work
who
all right let's see actually I'm ashamed
my time
oh wow I did not hear that go off did I
forget to start it or if I did I just
totally miss I don't know who that
alright let's see I do want to try I
hate to have so many nested spans but I
just want to I need to have it let's see
and that's not gonna work
all right Lily thing I had the same
problem what project was all right I
think I had the same problem on a
project I did last year so let me see
although it's possible that it was with
font icons and not SVG's and that would
be unfortunate because it might not work
I have it up on my other screen
[Music]
was a phone icon and I was able to use
vertical-align:bottom I did not have the
text in a separate span but the font
icon itself was actually very clear line
bottom so alright not sure that it'll
work since it's a phone icon but it's
worth shot
oh not bad
middle that's not too bad
that's not perfect but that's a lot
better
all right let me copy this in before I
forget on the SVG it's
vertical-align:middle all right great
but
[Music]
see that does it did you do
all right cool
now let's make sure these are the same
color I don't think we need
I actually this would be a cool way to
show
a cool way to show how to do variables
and incest all right so we're using the
same color here more than once right
that's that's repetitive anytime we're
being repetitive we should be able to
find a better way to do that what do
they call it dry do not do not repeat
okay so incest we have a cool way to
save values in this case we're gonna
save this color so let's call this fu s
yellow so fu s 4 Franciscan University
of Stephenville and then yellow because
it's a yellowy color and then we can put
this this hex color here now when we use
this down here we can say fu s yellow
and that's the color so if I say this we
should have this color I think I can get
rid of this now as well and then let's
see
Oh happen there I mess something up oops
guess semicolons alright cool
so see there we go now the font icon or
the SVG icon and the text are both the
same color and we've used this variable
now I guess it'll be cool to see what
the CSS is so on this side is the sass
but this is what actually gets sent to
the browser so you can see here like the
the variable isn't even there anymore
instead it's just the correct hex hex
code for that color and then you can see
instead of things being nested there's
its proper CSS so it's pretty cool
really useful feature and the cool thing
now it doesn't seem like much now
because it was only two but potentially
if we had a lot of different components
that we're all sharing that same color
and then let's say I go show this to the
other people in my department and they
say I really hate that yellow all I have
to do is go in here and change it I mean
potentially I could I could name this
something more generic like like link
color or accent color and then I could
change it to whatever color I want I get
it wouldn't make sense change the color
I guess if I'm calling it yellow so I
could do something like this link color
FUS yellow
blink color and then I could save that
and you can see it's already and my
editor picked up that that's the color
and if I go in here and give it a
refresh to be sure see it picks it up
too
now that actually makes even more sense
because now I I can still basically I
can have color variables for all my
entire color palette and actually let's
do that this is the color palette for
Franciscan University so - let's get rid
of I didn't want to there we go I
actually changed the yellow to make it a
bit darker so it's different I'm pulling
these from the from the style guide I
have it opened on my other screen so
yeah I don't I don't know if I think
I've shown you this before so this is a
style guide I made us at some point last
year this was the first thing I think I
ever successfully built in react and I
think this was done with I can't
remember if I did this with create react
app or with next I think I tried it with
both I don't remember what I ended up
going with
but anyway it's not it's certainly not
up to date with some of what I've been
doing lately but you could at least see
like some of the colors and the ideas of
like the direction that I wanted to go
with this so it probably wouldn't be too
much work to get this up to date but
until now I haven't no one except for
for me and like one other person that I
work with has ever even needed to
reference this so it hasn't been a
really high priority but anyway that's
where I got the colors from and so like
potentially then all I would have to do
is put in like let's say F us dark blue
in here and then it would change
automatically everywhere that I've used
link color so it could save a ton of
time alright so let me get rid of this
download text why haven't I taking that
out yet
let's get rid of that there's my title
card too let's see okay not bad need to
do the same thing for PSD as well I'm
still not 100% sure whether I'll keep
JPEG and PSD or whether I'll go back to
the old web in print we'll see I'm not
sure what do you all think people are
used to having it's a web in print
instead of select web print or the
options in reality they have the option
to get a JPEG version of the image and a
PSD version should I switch it up
because it's more accurate or should I
leave it like this I mean I guess this
is just a more technical way of
describing it this is just describing
what you would use it for you're not
really sure but I mean it's not it
wouldn't necessarily always be for web
if they wanted to put it into like a
PowerPoint that's not really a web but
you could you'd still want to use this
and not a PSD
all right so last thing I'm gonna do I
think yeah last thing I'm going to do is
I'm just gonna put the an icon here as
well and then we'll we'll commit this
and then I'll get to all the questions
so if you have questions put them in
there or start thinking of them now
because I'll get to them on probably
about five minutes all right so let's
see
[Music]
let's take this
see if this works without me having to
put parentheses around it
where did I put that Oh inside masonry
I'll shoot now I'm confused and this up
here at least makes more sense
area I mean here
I should've added this span
I see I mean I'm probably making this
more complicated but yeah then I should
have but the idea was maybe I ought to
make this into a component that I can
pass in this text too and then there
would be a lot more clean and I wouldn't
have to have all this SVG stuff in here
twice does that make sense
okay Patrick said or just use the
component that material you I already
gives you four file download icon well
that's I tried to figure out what that
component was earlier and I couldn't I
couldn't get it to work
so let's see oh actually no you're right
there was one that you just had to put
the SVG a stuff in my mistake I forgot
about that one okay yes so let's see
what do we need SVG icon that is a great
idea alright so bringing that in and
then let's bring in
yeah I could use that I do want it to
I didn't want to be able to pass in the
text there's something I can I can do
that maybe I can maybe I'm just not
looking right
okay
what I'm still gonna pull this in
all right let's see if that works
oops left an extra span in there it was
even in red I don't know how I missed
that one all right let's check that out
okay yet I mean it worked it's just not
giving me the correct color let's see
why I guess it's actually added the
color in
it's what they probably want me to pass
the color and yeah
oh this this ruins all my efforts over
here to have to pass this color and I
almost want to just put important on the
end so I don't have to change it but
I'll do it like this so let's add color
and there we go and then
let's do the same thing here but then
let's
there we go all right now now we have
our download icons okay not bad
that looks a little bit more legit all
right cool let me commit this and then
we'll do some question-and-answer stuff
here to finish up get this one in
all right so looks like there's a lot in
the live chat so I'm gonna scroll up to
where I left off and try to get through
as much as I can so since there's so
much I'm again I'm not definitely not
gonna read everything out so I'm just
gonna focus on the questions
most especially on questions from people
who are newer I definitely want to help
them to feel welcome not that I don't
appreciate all of you that that are here
frequently all right
all right so that's the all up on github
now awesome
okay
all right so found where I left off at
oh it looks like at some point
Joshua could not hear the stream so
sorry I see that at the time so I'm not
sure what the issue is it looks like it
doesn't look like anyone else was having
the same issue so anyway that I guess
let me know if that was ever resolved
and if you found out what the problem
was
I'm not sure if it was anything on my
end but if it was I definitely want to
know about it
so I can fix it
okay I do want to read this it says John
Anson said Jesse styled components
dot-com keeps your JSX code clean
because you don't mess it up with CSS
classes you build a CSS component and
style it style that and CSS it nests
just like s CSS next project yeah
actually that sounds cool
definitely check that out for the next
project remind me if I forget though if
if you're around cuz I'm not sure how
much longer this project will take I'm
thinking actually just to give you an
update I'm thinking this project may end
up being like another two weeks or so
not that it would take us that long to
complete it cuz it probably wouldn't but
it's probably gonna take that long for
me to get feedback so I did we had a
department meeting this morning and I
did tell everyone that we need to figure
out what exactly we want to update and
change in this and so I need everyone's
feedback so I'm just not really sure I
mean you know everyone's busy they all
have their own things going on so it's
probably not gonna be high on anyone's
priority list
so I will keep reminding everyone but
really it's not like we can't launch
this without the changes but it would
just be good to know about them and do
the changes before we finish because it
could possibly save us from doing some
work that we may end up either getting
rid of or changing so anyway so my
prediction is at least two more weeks I
didn't really think we'd be working on
it for that long but there's been a lot
of really nice improvements to this
project and a lot of extra things that
are really great to have like all the
testing that was I was not anticipating
that but I'm glad that we have it now
actually patrick said pretty sure that's
what he used in the last project yeah
now that you say that you're right I
think that was called installed
components I didn't even remember it I
was reading through it yeah I think it
was yeah I just remember the tag that I
had to use was style and then I would
have a space and then I read JSX and
that was the tag so I guess that was
style Cantona's not sure I remember what
it was called but I still remember how
to how to use it so I guess that's more
important
okay so skillful mess asks how do you
install react Sebastian says npm
install' save react yeah you can
definitely install react like that if
you're just getting started with react
though I think probably using create
react app would be the best way to go so
look up create react app go to their
github repo and then follow the
instructions there so it just depends on
your skill level right so create react
app is going to do a lot of things for
you to get you started so that you can
get right to the react and don't have to
worry about webpack so I'm not not
really sure what your skill level is in
terms of web pack but maybe you might
want to go with something like that or
next Jes also does a similar thing
okay Sebastian I just saw your comment
about making the buttons off each occupy
half the width of the cards alright
maybe I'll try that and see how that
looks
Wow okay so skillful mess is nine years
old Wow
that's awesome that you're you're able
to code and follow you know follow this
kind of stuff at 9 years old so that's
great I'm gonna say the same thing I
said to Joshua who was 10 years old as
if you get a chance please let me know
what what it's like what your motivation
is like for coding and how you got into
it at such a young age because I said I
have an 8 year old that I'd love to try
to get him interested in coding
skillful messes you should do a series
of the reddit programming challenges
actually we have someone doing
programming stuff challenges from reddit
I believe it's from reddit on the this
channel already so shoot what is it
called I can't remember what the title
was is called we have to look it up I
can't believe I have to look it up I see
it constantly
the daily programmer that's it so the
the series the daily programmer
on this channel free code camp channel
is is exactly that so so check that out
I'm I do not have time right now to do
another series and in fact the only
reason I can eat have time to do this is
because it's I'm doing my normal work
otherwise it would be it would be really
difficult to do something with this this
many hours every day consistently
okay cool I just saw Brian ahead
commented the separation line with the
link colors works well just don't think
the plain black text makes enough of a
distinction and we're talking about this
here so that just reminded me that I did
not leave that line in so I'll probably
end up putting that back in at some
point because I think I think that did
make a nice distinction so maybe I like
to see it on more than just one does I
just tested on one to see what I think
but what it really looks like but I
think that was kind of a nice nice
distinction than them just kind of
sitting there
okay I'm over halfway through the live
chat now so probably just not too much
longer till I get to the bottom so if
you have any questions that you haven't
put in here yet
I probably only have a few more minutes
Oh Patrick I just saw your comment about
the file download icon being included
already oh
Rohan says how does it do circular hover
animations where I'm not sure where it's
doing the circular hover I mean it does
like the the little ripple effect when
clicking so I'm not I'm not exactly sure
ever on if you're which hover animation
you're referring to
Emerson as does anyone know how to make
the dev tools look black yeah so it
looks like okay someone already answered
so just for anyone watching later on
they can't see the live chat it's really
easy for dev tool so you go into dev
tools like you normally would go up here
to the icon for the menu into settings
and then theme will be right up there at
the top and you can pick the darker the
light theme and obviously I picked the
dark theme and that's it it's so super
easy comes built-in
Alexander I see now that you're trying
to tell me to put the styles on the SVG
and not the span and so yeah you were
definitely right so I didn't see that
sooner
qsk i is the name says why is there no
super chat I've never tried using the
super chat so from what I understand the
super chat is just if you want to get
money from your stream so I'm currently
not interested in getting money for this
stream so I haven't tried super chat if
there's some other reason why I should
be using super chat let me know but I I
thought it was just if you wanted money
Isaiah says I'm having trouble deploying
my portfolio react router website to
github pages help okay
Isaiah's if you use create react app for
it
check out Gavin's pull request on my
project says Gavin just did the same
thing for this project that I'm working
on and it was maybe pull requests 35
somewhere around there so check out the
closed pool request I think it's the
whatever the last one from Gavin was if
you follow those steps of how he did
things it should work if you didn't use
create react react app I'm not really
sure I guess I'd have to check out how
you did things but create react app the
documentation on the github repo does
have a section for how exactly how to
get it to work on github pages
okay when I asked you all about what to
do what words I should use hear JPEG PSD
or whether I should put web and print so
some of the ideas here Gavin says keep
what they are used to in my opinion okay
Ron says go with web and print if people
are used to it
Curtis says leave it brian says JPEG PSD
that tells me exactly what I'm getting I
usually think of a print logo as some
sort of vector format John Hanson says
JPEG PSD it looks like we're pretty
split ok rhoann says maybe you could do
screen and print actually yeah that
would be more accurate than web and
print yeah maybe I like that idea yeah
okay I think about that screen if I do
change it from JPEG and PSD I think I'll
probably go with screen and print
instead of web and print
David said you should define the palette
in another file and then import it and
the others at CSS files yes that's
that's definitely what I which should be
done I was just kind of thought it might
be cool to just demonstrate it so I just
did it all right here
but obviously cuz I'm not even using
these yet but yeah ideally since I have
lots of different sass files I would
want to have let's say my own sass file
that I could call like palette or colors
or whatever I wanted to I could even
call it variables if I I could have
other things besides colors in there and
then any time I was going to use one of
those variables I could just include it
I could import it at the top and then
have access to it in these other files
so that that would be the better way to
go so I'll probably do that whenever I
work on the next page where I need to
use these then I'll probably pull them
out and do it properly Bryan says do
they have vector formats of those logos
I always prefer prefer vector yeah it's
actually surprisingly like somewhat not
straightforward to get different logo
formats around here so I agree I prefer
the vector formats so if I can get them
I'll try to get them but it's not like
I've requested them before and then been
given like JPEGs so I'm not really sure
what what's up with that but usually I
just kind of let it go and but but I'm
with you there
the vector versions of the logos would
be ideal
okay Sebastian I saw Sebastian mentioned
again when it wouldn't look better if
each button occupied half the card with
with the with centreline text I'll try
it out
Alexander says the top row navigation
and logos page is not looking good on
mobile will you fix that
yes so the idea is so right right now
this to give everyone an idea right yeah
it looks terrible it's really bad
the idea is to change this into a select
input or I could drop down menu once it
gets to a certain so probably I don't
want it to drop onto two lines so
probably really early on it's going to
go to a drop-down maybe I could probably
do with a little bit less space between
these and it would still work but at
some point it'll go to a drop down mine
blocks coder says I like your free code
camp website Jessie actually like the
the free code camp website is not it's
not a really mine so I just volunteer
and do this for free code camp there's a
lot of other people that volunteer and
do other things and that it worked on
the website and so I I haven't actually
contributed at all to the free code camp
website although that would be cool to
do someday for now I'm just just on
these videos but thanks though
okay alright so I've gotten to the end
of the chat
I've got through all the questions still
got a few few suggestions and you could
try out on on this but definitely
looking better than it did at the
beginning and we learned how to use
SVG's within material UI and to utilize
their SVG icon component so that was
pretty cool like what else yeah I mean
other than that I mean use some basic
stuff but I learned a little bit about
sass along the way so not bad not a bad
job if I haven't looked at the time in
quite a while but oh yeah almost two and
a half hours for today's stream so a
good time to wrap it up thanks so much
for everybody that stuck around we still
have people still watching after two and
half hours so thank you thank you all
for watching and you know everybody
that's gonna watch this later on and I
really appreciate it I I'll be back
tomorrow tomorrow's gonna be a weird
time I have a meeting scheduled at 2:30
and then I also have a doctor's
appointment
at 10:30 so Oh sometime tomorrow morning
I'll put on YouTube and then on Twitter
when I'm gonna strain I really want to
stream tomorrow it might end up having
to be a short stream at a weird time but
depending on how long my doctor's
appointment is maybe I can do a stream
from like 1:00 to 2:00 Eastern Time that
seems like that that might be doable but
I'll let you know tomorrow so anyway
thanks again for watching and for all
your help in the live stream and for the
pool requests and it's just it's just
overwhelmingly generous of you oh I
really appreciate it and I'll be back
tomorrow
have a great day